[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT: One of the
maladies of the modern age
is that, even though
collectively we have more
than we've ever
dreamed possible,
we remain perpetually
dissatisfied.
It's almost like we are
wired never to be content.
And that seems to be the case.
I mean, it's been
written that we
are insatiable wanting
machines, designed to desire.
And so, in some ways,
that has made us reach out
and transcend boundaries.
We didn't stay in the caves.
We haven't stayed on the planet.
We went to the moon.
We crisscrossed the skies.
We extend and we transcend.
But on the other hand,
that exploratory itch,
that genetic pull that
makes us tread forth, always
in search of the insatiable
deliciousness of the new,
the wholly other, the
[NON-ENGLISH SPOKEN]
--of the unfamiliar also makes
[NON-ENGLISH SPOKEN] day-to-day
life kind of banal.
Again, it's kind of sad.
Because the very
same quality that
makes us these
majestic creatures that
soar above the heavens and
transcend their batteries
has made us perpetually
dissatisfied neurotic beings,
living in urban centers,
drowning in consumption
in an over-capitalist,
bloated system that
can no longer satiate us.
Always wanting something
else, until we're
overwhelmed and overweight
and immobilized by how spoiled
we've become.
And yet, we enjoy
very little of it.
So what do we do?
How do we find a
way to leverage,
and combine, and reconfigure
the tension of this situation?
That we always want
more has made us great,
but that we always
want more almost
makes us kind of miserable.
And so, I don't know.
I haven't resolved that yet--
I haven't resolved that yet.
[SIGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]